if later on tonight I asked you to be my
girlfriend hey what's going on guys man
this was a very interesting week to say
the least and we all know that it was
fourth of July weekend and it happened
to fall on Saturday not for me when it
comes to like these holidays it's really
a great way for me to relax because most
of the time when I meet up just kidding
or you wouldn't you know Barton Joe it's
always usually about work but when it
comes to the what the help come here
what are you doing it's gonna leave
that's cool
interrupt my video and you know go into
your cage and fall asleep yeah [ __ ] you
but yeah when we meet up is usually
about work and there's a very few times
that we actually get to unwind and relax
with friends that has nothing to do with
growing our business or comedy channels
and just kidding news this Davis o
comedy vet yeah oh yeah oh yeah I've
never been so uncomfortable in my life
so fourth of July for us is one of those
reasons for us to get together and just
cook our asses off now if you guys don't
know this about me one of my favorite
things to do on earth is cooking now one
of the dishes that I've known for that I
bring to every single potluck is my
gumbo today we're gonna be cooking the
shrimp gumbo and we have ourselves
ingredients for gumbo you know I'm
saying [ __ ] what I'm saying now I know
what you're thinking why is the Asian or
even Korean American even thinking about
making gumbo for a potluck it's because
it's none of your [ __ ] business and
for me I like gumbo so much that I've
actually developed my own recipe and I
got this whole secret like secret herbs
and spice thing going on that I don't
want to share with people even though
it's pretty common that's right it's the
powder that's gonna make the chowder the
seasoning that's gonna give you a boner
but you know what because you gotta know
that every single home chef that's
really dumb always has a recipe that
they don't want to share I just want
somebody to ask me what the recipe is so
I can say to him if I told you I have to
[ __ ] kill you
killer
hey you guys know you're talking [ __ ]
friendly it's a friendly barbecue finish
the line huh you can't always have it
your way okay but if you guys have never
made gumbo before in your life just know
that one of the most important building
blocks of flavor for a gumbo is the root
so as they say in the south if you [ __ ]
up on the roof it might as well be poop
that's that's made it up on the spot
when you cook your rule you have to do
it a fairly low heat so you don't burn
it but my god for 45 minutes I stirred
that [ __ ] like I was said to felling so
instead you get your brother to do this
thing work away boy I hope your arm
falls off then of course you have to add
your vegetables which is of course the
Holy Trinity which consists of celery
onions and of course peppers now for me
I like to use red peppers and green
peppers but you know you guys can use
whatever you want I've seen some people
use uh pasilla peppers you know teach
their own now for me when I cook I don't
really cook by tradition even though
that's where I start off I kind of
cooked to my flavor palette so if my
gumbo actually don't use okra and yes I
understand that the original reason why
gumbo is called gumbo is because the
right from okra well [ __ ] you I don't
like it and of course as you begin to
cook it'll start to change color so
first off when it starts for a few
minutes it'll look like a wet sandy
brown color then it'll go into like a
deep milk chocolate and after that it'll
start getting to a brick red which is
the color that I'm looking for other
people typically yes they go into a
darker color Roo but for me I don't got
time for that [ __ ] but once the room is
done I add the Holy Trinity in there
with the herbs and spices and I kind of
let it bloom in that hot oil Roux
mixture yes
you let your spices bloom and they'll
take that much better then after that
you just add your stock a delicious
stuff that I've made myself or bought by
Swanson whatever same thing anybody got
time to always make stopped I got time
for that [ __ ] I'm a busy man
Fe I'm coming after you baby but
basically if you have a large quantity
and you let that stew for about three to
four hours it should relatively look
like this now one of the biggest reasons
why I love cooking is based on the fact
that I like
sharing food with people for me I I
could cook for myself but when you make
the dish and other people eat it and
they thoroughly enjoy it their joy
becomes your joy I think that's the main
reason why most people like cooking in
the first place it's not because you
want to sit there and make yourself the
most amazing dish it's because you like
sharing the experience that you have
with the food
me you understand why this is so
delicious Kasich made it with love yeah
it tastes like [ __ ] now because of the
way you're talking you would think that
the fatter you are the more you don't
want to share but that's not true at all
the fatter you are you just got to make
more so you can't share it but that's
the basics of how to make gumbo you can
go ahead and find your own ingredients
and learn how to make it yourself if you
guys want to know my secret recipe I'm
going to have to kill you
nope death doesn't stay in the same
token as they get you tokens that
Captain Morgan respectively mocking and
good I'm sorry for carrying it over no
tank that's just a Jack Daniels s finger
with a 13 that baby don't hurt me
see I was just prepping us believe me I
don't usually read these things on
purpose
I asked you